and it's so harrowing to think what you
would do in certain instances you know
and if you have the because I even
notice like
if I get like scared at night you know
yeah I'll even say like
is somebody there you know like
somebody's gonna be like
yeah you're lying in bed and you hear a
noise type screen yeah like I'll get you
know I mean I'm tough and everything but
I will also in addition to being tough I
will like go be like you know hey is
somebody that like I'll do like um
who's you know yeah yeah and like
they're gonna say something back like
I'm here you know burglar yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it's always a burglar
in my mind you know it's always that
kind of Home Alone s type of fella you
think it's someone coming in to steal
items and just hoping no one wakes up
and asks is anyone there yeah and you
just yeah
I think about home invasion
most of the day
yeah I mean
you do you ever yell I have a gun
no that's a good idea yeah
I have a gun
oh that sounded pretty with authority
right I have a gun now when you say
you're a tough guy see I would mess it
up when you say you're a tough guy in
the in that moment you're in your home
someone's coming in you don't know what
they're about do you feel tough
at first I don't right but then I have
to remember hey you are tough so then I
will be able to be tough tough meaning I
know how to fight do you do uh I'll go
to like Jiu Jitsu classes okay all right
but not a ton though okay just enough to
like maybe
I'm a huge fan of it sure but I am a
like I'm a one stripe white belt and
there are
four-year-olds that are that or
seven-year-olds probably not four
but uh you know so it's not it's not an
insane thing to get but I mean
I do know that once those once so say
say there's somebody I hear something
right yeah I get out of bed
I go over and then I realize the
scariest part is you have to turn a
corner in your home that's oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so from now on I turn and
I go like I'll turn and be like hey you
know I will turn like
I'm here or something like that like
something so that if there is somebody
there about to attack me they're not
just gonna get onto something that's
like sinking away yeah I had a um a
t-shirt I bought at Kanye West Life of
Pablo tour it was a like a double XL
airbrush t-shirt and on the front it had
a airbrush painting of donda West okay
and on the back it had an airbrush
painting of Robert Kardashian Kim
Kardashian's late father and O.J
Simpson's attorney
I was at home
um a few years back and it was New
Year's it was a couple days after New
Year's and I had a New Year's party
where there'd been balloons and [__] so
but the house was still you know uh
messy from it
um middle of the night uh the alarm goes
off screaming alarm like the loud ass
someone just came in through the door
alarm oh so I get out [__] threadbare
boxers done to West Robert Kardashian
t-shirt I reached behind the bed for my
Easton bat and it's not there oh I must
have been showing it off downstairs okay
so now I'm going I'm like I'm out in the
uh in the hallway and I'm like I gotta
Rush down the stairs which had two turns
to it oh God and I'm like I've got
nothing
except maybe the T-shirt to buy me some
time of confusion like if I jumped out
and you saw a big down to West and I
spun around and there was an equally big
Robert Kardashian and it said rest in
power you'd be like huh like you got
[__] give me a minute holy [__] that's a
really nice just a hologram show in my
exactly Amaya Coachella or just like wow
that's a really nice way to pay tribute
to your parents right and then I could
[__] I don't know any but you could
do something I could do some Miss Piggy
like karate it's fine she would fly
through there and uh I go down and it's
pitch black and I'm just in the darkness
and right then a balloon decides to lose
just enough helium that it floats down a
big ass Yellow Balloon floats down right
in front of my face I've never like it's
an Asian guy is more like
you haven't I've never been murdered by
a clown but I bet right before you're
murdered by a clown a big yellow balloon
and I said out loud not like this
I was so
existentially scared and it was I was
just like not not now
not like this
I love that man murdered by a clown in
adonda West Robert Kardashian what a way
to go though yeah I mean it'd be in the
paper
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one